Manish Mehta covers the Jets for the New
York Daily News and he had some
interesting things yesterday with you
know your miking up Sam darn 'old did
the coach no and why is Adam GaSe all
upset I'm just shocked that they had him
miked up in the first place and Arnold
and mination joins us now take us behind
the scenes how does this happen that NFL
Films goes in and then who needs to
approve who gets miked up for a football
game yeah every team has to have their
coach and quarterback miked up at some
point during the season the Jets
actually agreed to have Donald miked up
for their Sunday night game against the
Browns but he obviously didn't play so
his motto
yeah the player has to get clearance or
have to clear you know this of course
and the organization you know public
relations is involved in this as well
but to answer your original question
yeah Adam GaSe knew that he was marked
up the Jets actually embraced the fact
that he was miked up there is a danger
however when you miked up a player for a
prime-time game because the network in
this case ESPN can turn around those
clips in game whereas if you had the
player miked up for a one o'clock or a
four o'clock game on a Sunday NFL Films
wouldn't use what they have until later
in the week for whatever programming
that they have so the team would have
more of an opportunity to perhaps be a
part of the vetting process but in this
case when you're dealing with real-time
you know an NFL Films representative on
site give ESPN the clear batch of clips
and then ESPN obviously decides what
they want to air what they don't want to
air my understanding is that actually
people high up on the totem pole of NFL
Films you know we're not happy that this
got cleared so they weren't happy with
one of their employees in essence and
clearly the Jets don't like their a
franchise quarterback being poked fun at
for what like 24 36 hours yeah I feel
bad for Sam but it was a great moment if
I'm NFL Films didn't I get what I want
to get here it makes a great
conversation it's an attaining it's
certainly much better than the bland
stuff that you typically hear in these
mics up tempest
Aereo's I'm not debating that it makes
an awesome conversation but if you're
the team you have a shared understanding
with the league that if your player is
going to be miked up you're gonna get
you know your typical hooting and
hollering you know your grunting after
getting tackled really bland stuff
nothing as juicy as what we saw this
time so I do think that the team that
burned in in a way it's not as if the
Dan Patrick show Mike Delph and Arnold
or the New York Daily News miked ups and
Arnold now this is the league dealing
with one of its teams and and clearly
you don't see comments like this being
here for a reason
did Adam GaSe make things better or
worse yesterday with his comments
look I think you picked off the bottom
all and gave more important things to
concern himself with that's not to say
that he shouldn't have handled this
matter the way that he had on yesterday
can actually agree with the way that he
handled it he said that you know the
team's gotta think twice now about
getting the players miked up now again
there is a rule the players do have to
get miked up each game so I'm not sure
what the Jets could do but they're put
in an awkward position at the end of the
day Dan you you know you've been around
the NFL long enough to know that seeing
those is a common phrase you hear a lot
worst thing on sideline so I think NFL
people don't pay that much attention to
it but when you look at social media
there's memes all over the place about
Sam to ROP so I think you know that is
to fall out that the team is not happy
about I think the bigger picture here is
okay we caught him saying it but to me
the bigger picture is why was he seeing
ghosts out there why was it it felt like
ill-prepared to face the Patriots what
what they were gonna bring defensively
hey you hit the nail on the head for
preparation by the coaching staff it was
a poor communication by the offensive
line so it's poor execution by spamed
Arnold you could put the blame on a lot
of different people for why they were
non-competitive the other night
it obviously behaves with the head coach
in preparation but you can't absolve and
Arnold we see is the one who made the
off-balance throws you know ultimately I
just think that this team has not been
prepared too many times
entering games whether Sam barber was
the quarterback or Luke Falk was the
quarterback or Trevor Simeon was the
quarterback that is an indictment on
Adam GaSe it's pretty cut-and-dried to
me it's not respect i I just wonder as
we move I don't know how good Sam darn
Allah is like dude do we have a sense of
how good he is or is going to be we've
seen enough flashes I think in the 16
games that he's played to believe that
he can be a very good player at the very
least I look at his floor and Tony Romo
you know I think he could potentially be
a Matt Ryan well Philip Rivers impact
player and I think if things go
perfectly for him he could be in that
Ben Roethlisberger and Roger said the
success rate but he has skills and there
was a reason why he was the number three
taking the draft and you saw two weeks
ago he was the AFC Offensive Player of
the Week for what he did against the
Cowboys he has a tremendous amount of
ability I think he will be a difference
maker in this league for a very long
time I think he's going to be a very
good player regardless of who was head
coaches that being said the head coach
is going to be absolutely pivotal if
this player has a chance to be an elite
player you see the Patriots twice a year
what do you make of them and are they
the class of the NFL they are because I
thought that they would have a very good
defense this year I did not think that
we would see a duplicate of the 85 Bears
or the 2000 and Ravens but if you're
being honest about this assessment they
have played every bit as good and have
look every bit as dominant as those
types of defenses and there's a lot of
football left to be played you know two
and a half months left and the playoffs
for the Super Bowl of course but they
are so sound on defense they are so
creative on defense that's a clear
reflection on Bill Belichick the way
that they can infuse the Jets and you
can say the Jets aren't a very good team
and you're probably right about that but
the confusion that they caused with that
that all-out blitz which wasn't always
an all-out blitz they had six or seven
guys at the line of scrimmage but
oftentimes they only blitz for guys the
Jets had no idea which four it was going
to be that to me is just a credit to how
Bill Belichick teaches those guys I
don't know how he does it I don't know
what the teaching points are but
everybody on that defense seems to be an
extremely smart football player they are
so sound and what they do they don't
make mistakes and if that continues I
can't see anybody in the AFC or the NFC
that's going to stop them because as
long as Tom Brady is healthy there's
always going to be a quality player he
might not be at that dominant player he
used to be but a quality Tom Brady
comforted with a dominant defense is a
it's a tough combination to be finished
thank you for joining us and good luck
two Jets this season okay
Manish Mehta it covers the judge for the
New York Daily News for more Dan Patrick
show tune in to audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV stream for free on BR live or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]